[Musique]
et
messieurs bonjour merci d'être sur le
plateau de tv soixante dix huit pour ce
vide que nous consacrons au deuxième à
la deuxième édition du festival électro
chic qui va avoir lieu donc dans un mois
alors je vais vous présenter donc
ludovic moreau vous êtes
secrétaire général à londres théâtre et
centre d'art à vélizy-villacoublay
d'accord thomas ogier racontez moi tout
je suis le responsable du studio
d'enregistrement et de répétition à
saint cyr l'école qui s'appelle le
casoar décor et vous me ferez valeur
alors moi je suis directeur artistique
pendant du du collectif sound motion
d'accord alors vous avez tous les trois
vous jouez tous les trois roulent dans
ce deuxième festival électro chic on va
remonter un tout petit peu d'eau qu'il
existe depuis l'année dernière
il est à l'origine de qui vous pouvez
nous expliquer il devient donc c'est un
projet à l'origine de l'undd directeur
de l'ange berger qui voulait faire un
festival électro vivant sur le
territoire de vélizy voilà où il est
depuis deux ans maintenant et suite à
une conversation avec le directeur des
affaires culturelles de versailles
georges fleury gilbert voilà ils ont eu
envie de travailler ensemble et on a eu
l'idée voilà en fonction des deux des
festivals ou des projets électro qui
existe déjà en france de l'axé sur un
territoire qui apportait beaucoup de
talent qui sont maintenant reconnus
internationalement de grands groupes
en fait qu'ils sont nés dans les années
90 2000 autour de de cette zone de très
grands partent donc on aère daf peur
phoenix de secret si alex gopher la luz
à d'autres et donc ça continue
apparemment ça continue de la relève est
assurée d'accord alors vous tome 1 vous
avez
vous êtes donc à saint cyr vous avez une
programmation particulière raconté mon
un peu quel est le lien vous d'abord ça
va avoir lieu au cinéma les yeux d'elsa
oui tout à fait alors c'était déjà le
cas l'année dernière on vous voulez
programmé un groupe qui répète à
saint-cyr-l'ecole wii qui tombait pile
poil dans ce registre
donc il faut un groupe électro rock donc
il mélange les machines et les
instruments plus traditionnels et on a
eu l'idée aussi de diffuser le film de
daft punk interstella et cette année du
coup on s'est dit pourquoi pas garder ce
concept de 2 mai de vidéos et du coup on
a programmé deux groupes qui sont de la
romance est basique dimanski qui sont
tous les deux
deux artistes qui sont très intéressés
par l'idée tout ce qui est imagé
fonctionne comme ça finalement voilà ce
serait se produisent à la fois des
images est l'année de la musique sont
voilà d'accord alors vous visiterez
valeur à quoi on va parler peu plus fin
on va pas vous faire chacun son tour
tout le temps dites moi donc votre
collectif soit de motion ça existe
depuis que même temps alors
officiellement c'est existe depuis 2015
d'accord vous êtes combien on est
actuellement on est à peu près 13
personnes d'accord les y viennent ça
alors c'est ça alors voici ce qu'il fait
là la caractéristique de cette motion
c'est qu'en fait on est tous des des
jeunes de versailles et des environs et
l'idée est un peu de pouvoir justement
mutualiser un peu les les passions qu on
avait chacun dans notre coin pour la
musique électronique est bon un peu plus
récemment des deux personnes qui sortent
un peu du cercle des élites qui nous ont
rejoints mais voilà l'idée c'est quand
même de pouvoir promouvoir vraiment la
musique qu'on aime dans les yvelines
elle sera sur paris parfois on va faire
enquête et justement des événements en
région parisienne va donc vos
prestations c'est vous animer une soirée
comme des dj c'est ça alors on va voir
justement une partie où effectivement on
va organiser des des éléments c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'on va faire donc oui
j'imagine alors ça peut pas tout à fait
une soirée années au fait c'est quoi ce
soir en collaboration avec le collectif
achats selecto d'accord vous êtes donc
vous serez donc deux de collectifs
plutôt fait juste avant c'est en fait on
aura donc aussi un plateau avec la
webradio dit culture donc le jeudi après
midi à l'atelier numérique web radio sur
laquelle on a une émission biais de
madère par ailleurs en tant que cette
motion est enfin là donc on va aussi
travailler avec le théâtre de langue les
vendredis et samedis sion ok donc ce
festival qui dure trois jours
lieu sur quatre dans quatre villes
différentes donc on a dit vélizy saint
cyr vous s'est jouée en josas et
versailles bien sûr comment ça se passe
alors les gens peuvent eux le public va
pouvoir aller de d'événement en
événement de concert au concert fausse
coûtant 4 comment vous faut vous
confèrent les gens va falloir faire des
choix mais on peut faire des fêtes de
choix mais on peut on peut quand même
terminé une soirée dans un autre endroit
que voilà là où on a commencé on compte
c'est le cas les trois soirs les trois
soirs en fait et parce que ça finit tard
j'imagine votre foi rien vous à londres
la première soirée à termine vers 23
heures ce qui fait qu ensuite on peut
enchaîner avec monza le vendredi et le
samedi
là on s'est plutôt une soirée on arrive
puisque lundi sa voix la ccbe forrester
enfin disons que là dessus on peut la
suivre à partir de 20h30 si on veut mais
on peut la rejoindre à minuit une heure
voire plus d'accord la nuit est à nous
génial et alors dites moi cette année il
ya une nouveauté
vous avez organisé un tremplin rock un
tremplin électro important mais c'est
que c'est dans l'argent dans l'esprit
indépendant par dudka
il ya aussi en chansons mais là c'est
vraiment sur des candidats ça y est
c'est culturel s'est clos voilà depuis
le 31 janvier donc on a choisi cinq
candidats on va bientôt communiquer le
nom des candidats beaucoup de monde on a
une vingtaine de
le groupe katz et qui ont concouru et
donc on a choisi avec plusieurs éminents
jury c5 qui vont donc représenter devant
le public de vélizy leurs morceaux et
doit choisir en afrique est joué et
jouent tous trois morceaux dont une
reprise une reprise voilà qui
choisissent de la même
chacun choisit sa reprise et donc à la
l'issue delà de la présentation de
chacun des groupes
le public choisit c'est vraiment le
public tout celle qu'il a choisie
revoilà et le prix c'est d'être oui
c'est d'être programmée l'année suivante
dans la programmation in an au même
titre que voilà toutes les toutes les
stars et les groupes concon programme
dans le cadre du festival d'accord donc
l'année des jeux si j'ai bien compris
les groupes étaient plutôt de des
yvelines
cette année format que non non pas que
je vous vois avec vos yeux vous dit non
non non pas que il ya été il y avait des
groupes effectivement de versailles
avait d'ailleurs une soirée autour de la
de la jeune création versaillaise il y
avait deux autres soirées avec des
groupes qui venait de france et même de
l'international d'accord et cette année
pareil cette année pareil mais plus
voilà plus plus encore autour du
national et de l'international d'accord
international juste c'est qu' il est
temps de roms qui sont serbes
voilà gâtés des choix swindle et
viennent de
de hollande voilà il ya des américains
aussi yann perreau il ya quasiment que
les américains aient la soirée du 17 17
mars à londres
sinon il ya pas mal de voilà deux
parisiens et et à saint cyr l'école
il faut aussi bien il sourit deux jeunes
franciliens
le premier bâtiment ce qui a sorti deux
ep ont pas et le deuxième de la romance
a sorti un album
donc ce sont des groupes qui existe
depuis 2016 donc on voulait
c'est de la musique électronique c'est
un arc est quand même assez jeune donc
on voulait montrer au public la jeunesse
après de la romance il en est pas à son
premier coup d'essai parce qu'il a eu un
premier gros qui s'appelait électronique
conspiration et avant il était batteur
pour vegastar née d'un groupe
électronique métal qui a fait entre
autres la première partie de ligne qui
me parle quand il était en france on a
écouté très bien donc ce sont des jeunes
mais qui ont qui ont déjà du lourd a
proposé à propos d'un passé voilà c'est
ça très bien je cromprends bon où
justement parlant de jeunes moins jeunes
ce festival j'ai l'impression qu'il est
ou n'est pas ouverte qu'aux jeunes
finalement il est ouvert aussi aux
enfants on peut dire donc quelle forme
ils ouverts à tous dès l'instant qu'on a
envie de danse et la musique
mais effectivement il ya une une boum
électro le samedi après midi
quel hacker lieu à londres
[Musique]
dont 15 heures 17 heures et c'est à
partir de 11 12 ans jusqu'à 16 17
et puis ensuite il ya un atelier bin oui
on va dire un travail sur le le matériel
qui fait du bruit on va dire pour faire
de la musique qui j'aurai mme la base de
la de la musique technologiques toujours
à londres
donc on peut faire la boum et ensuite
poursuivre avec cet atelier d'accord je
crois qu'ils aient la même chose aussi à
versailles avec le groupe saint michel
je veux dire c'est donc l'école d'archi
esclaves c'est ça aussi c'est un
workshop
voilà c'est à dire que c'est on
travaille on se forme d'une certaine
manière avec l'artiste qui transmet
auprès des participants
sa façon de créer sa façon de jouer de
la musique
donc j'imagine que tout ça c'est sur
inscription c'est chaud etc
voilà donc il faut aller voir le
programme qui est chargé vous avez un
événement particulier un quelque chose
de phare vous vous bien sûr c'est votre
soirée
alors que la note soit qui est bien
entendu quelque chose qu'on a on a
beaucoup de beaux coups de coeur mais
déjà travaillé d'ailleurs je voudrais
citer la mérite de jouy en josas quand
même qui nous qui nous accompagne aussi
sur le projet de la sueur et du du jeudi
soir mais je fonce voir aussi ce qu'on
va faire à londres et je peins nous en
tout cas en tant que ça de motion
kousair que c'est quand même une chance
immense de pouvoir jouer soit dans les
entractes ou après des artistes comme
kenny dope uri davis junior qui ont
énormément apporté quand même d'accra
aux musiques house et techno qui sont
pour nous extrêmement importante donc le
fait de pouvoir les avoir là dans les
yvelines
c'est une chance je pense est assez
exceptionnel parce qu'en général quand
il passait plutôt sur paris c'est dans
les très grands lieux où il ya beaucoup
de gens qui admirent et là le fait de
les avoir justement bas juste à côté de
chez nous c'est quand même quelque chose
d'assez exceptionnel
d'accord mais écoutez poursuivre dix ans
on n'a pas parlé du off qu'est ce qui va
se passer en fille aura des conférences
des choses comme ça la boum et l'atelier
dont je parlais ça fait partie
mais il ya aussi des choses à l'école de
musique et de danse de vélizy
villacoublay
il ya des choses aussi à viroflay il ya
des choses aussi à versailles le multi
se renseignait l'on regardé sur internet
sur le site à vous très vite donc
comment se porte la french touch c'est
dur à dire la relève est assurée vous
notez quelque chose de particulier ben
c'était un peu l'idée c'est un peu
l'idée du premier festival
là on est vraiment plus dans une phase
très hâtive hit électro on se donne
moins de frontière que la dernière
soirée une soirée américaine si on veut
qu'ils étaient importantes voilà par
rapport à la
l'explosion de la hausse dans les années
90 d'accord entre autres ok bah écoute
et merci beaucoup à tous les trois ou
vous retrouve donc bas d'ici un mois
sans faute et puis on fera les choix qui
s'imposent
on se comprend 4 on verra merci à très
bientôt mais c'est tout
[Musique]